[Música]
aquí comienza ella soy de france 24 mi
nombre es ángela gómez y para este
episodio el tema es una revisión de la
sexualización del deporte a propósito de
los múltiples ejemplos que se vieron con
ocasiones de los juegos olímpicos y
paralímpicos de tokio estas son algunas
de las historias
los juegos olímpicos y paralímpicos de
tokio una ventana para revisar la
desigualdad y los señalamientos a las
mujeres atletas restringidas en sus
elecciones de vestuario la discusión
contra la sexualización se abrió al
espectro internacional en julio semanas
antes de las justas la selección noruega
de voley playa femenino protestó por el
uniforme tradicional que para hombres
admite pantalones cortos y camiseta y
para mujeres un bikini ellas usaron
shorts en una muestra al mundo que les
costó una multa de la federación europea
de voleibol por 1500 euros
vélez cata
porque viste lo que queremos hacer un
cambio porque no queremos que el deporte
excluya a nadie informamos hoy
deseamos que sea inclusivo por la
diversidad campe clea hay varios países
y regiones que no permiten que las
mujeres se vistan de la manera que
establecen las reglas
nosotros desearíamos que se centrarán en
el deporte y no en la ropa
plasma viste frost como resultado la
multa la pagará la federación noruega y
no el equipo junto al compromiso de
revisar sus normas de uniforme la misma
semana elevó su voz desde reino unido la
doble campeona mundial de salto de
longitud paralímpica olivia green quien
dijo sentirse decepcionada porque una de
las fuerzas creyó necesario informarme
que mis shorts de sprint eran demasiado
cortos e inapropiados me quedé sin
palabras
bolivia quien es titular en los
paralímpicos de tokio desencadenó una
investigación y declaró que necesitaba
sentirse cómoda y ligera para competir
además de recordar que lleva nueve años
usando el mismo tipo de shorts ya en el
marco de los olímpicos la selección
alemana de gimnasia eligió un uniforme
que cubre de cuello a pies en lugar del
tradicional mal jot
queríamos mostrar que cada mujer y todo
el mundo debería poder decidir qué
ponerse la nadadora alice deben fue
noticia por resaltar la falta de
diversidad en su deporte siendo la
primera integrante afro del equipo
olímpico promovió la gorra south
especialmente diseñada para pelo crespo
y rechazada por la federación
internacional de natación porque no
sigue la forma natural de la cabeza en
un tema que aún es polémico para el
deporte la atleta transexual flor belga
bert levanto pesas y también la cabeza
contra la creencia de ventaja física
para quienes compiten con un sexo
diferente al de su nacimiento fue la
primera mujer abiertamente trans en
participar y después de las justas
anunció su retiro cumplido su sueño
olímpico
para conversar del tema la invitada es
la arquera colombiana valentina acosta
de quien participó en los juegos
olímpicos de tokio
valentina bienvenida y cada deporte
exige una composición corporal diferente
para los atletas cada atleta explota su
propia estética nos falta como público
entender que las deportistas no son ni
bonitas ni feas sino profesionales
bueno si mira la verdad es que ahora que
estamos pues en los olímpicos estos
olímpicos se ha permitido a explorar
muchas situaciones que pasan en el
deporte y está dando como un espejo y lo
que la sociedad actualmente hemos
aprendido de que hay diferentes tipos de
cuerpos todos son atléticos porque todos
corresponden a lo que hace pues el
deporte ahora nos en las piezas más
delgado entonces los que serán más
gruesos y unos que éramos musculosos
otros que simplemente no lo son
estamos hablando de entender un poco eso
sobre todo siento que yo vengo de los
olímpicos han logrado como éste está
esta edición han logrado cómo mostrar
eso y que las personas sean más
conscientes al respecto que para no hay
deportes que desde su propia forma como
como la historia que tiene el deporte
tiene mucha sexualización por ejemplo el
caso de volibol de playa en donde pues
muchas veces se despiden las mismas
deportistas de utilizar
y trajes de baño con los por el estilo
que pueden ser un poco incómodas para
ellas y conocimos del caso no recuerdo
de qué equipo era que las deportistas
decidieron salir con algo que era un
poco más tapado pues sin dejar de ser
una
uniforme pues también he pegado el
cuerpo pues cosas por el estilo pero
entonces siento que ya empieza a quebrar
un poco y dos paradigmas que tenemos
respecto a ciertos deportes
bueno y qué pasa la gente hables piensa
que un deportista se quiere ver bien es
por las personas pagan muchas veces de
que la gente considera que el deportista
el atlético por qué por qué pues esa
quiere verse bien por ejemplo ha llevado
a recibir comentarios pedía pues que yo
me arreglaba ya era porque yo me vaya
era modelar y pues no sea la verdad no
funciona así uno como un ser humano las
reglas no se arreglan si quiere ver si
bien si quiere estar
como pues como quiera realmente
y pues eso no tiene no ha ligado con
quién lo va a ver qué comentarios van a
recibir lastimosamente por lo mismo que
te contaba el deporte es que entran un
poco en el modo de visualización por la
misma naturalidad del deporte y la
historia que tiene el deporte
las personas pueden sentirse en el
derecho de hacer comentarios que yo sé
que a muchos les va a molestar y la
verdad eso podría significar como un
como de meditar lo que ellas hacen como
atletas entonces se crea esa barrera
entre a no por escrito veredicto ni está
pero entonces que es ambiental en todas
y todo lo que haya hecho todo lo que ha
trabajado por estar allí entonces
ahorita se están descubriendo muchas de
las situaciones y está quedando más
conciencia lo cual me parece muy bueno
pero pues falta un poco más mire
inicialmente se había dicho que usted
tendría que cubrir sus tatuajes para
poder competir finalmente no fue así
pero este tipo de requisitos si pelean
con los uniformes en la mayoría de
disciplinas que obligan a las mujeres a
mostrar en la mayor cantidad de piel
posible usted cree que esto es necesario
que los uniformes sean así de
reveladores o deberíamos replantearnos
las necesidades según los deportes
bueno mira realmente es el primero lo de
los tatuajes y yo tuve que cubrir menos
para mi competencia y pues las razones
por las que me pidieron cubrir pues eran
como razones que era más como una
conjunción entre la parte pues de las
directivas de los jueces de torneo
entonces pues yo quería tener como un
tema aparte pero respecto a los
uniformes siento que los atletas debían
tener la libertad de escoger que los
hace sentir cómodos porque tampoco es
que digamos que la mujer se tiene que
cubrir para evitarse sexualizada si uno
se siente cómodo pues con el vestido de
baño pequeño para voley playa por
ejemplo siguiente cómodo y me gusta
estar así y no le molesta y me parece
bien que el atleta vaya sin peros y
también bien en protesta que no le gusta
que le parece incómodo que realmente
preferiría utilizar algo como los shorts
una lycra o cosas por el estilo debería
estar en la libertad en donde la atleta
puede llegar y presentarse con ello
habló que la haga sentir más cómoda que
la permita le permita dar un mejor
desempeño porque yo también van la
confianza
porque la solución para evitar la
sexualización no descubrir a la mujer y
siento que es algo que tampoco pues la
gente lo ve así es que aquí es sexual
izan porque está lista en falda o sea no
las cosas no funcionan así eso base en
el respeto entonces creo primero que
debería haber una libertad la libertad
en donde las mujeres los hombres pues
realmente las personas puedan decidir
saber sobre su cuerpo que hacer cómo
lucir lo como como pues por ejemplo en
el caso de mi deporte
yo no puedo ponerme en faldas cortas y
entiendo también el reglamento y cosas
por el estilo
y me pongo cuando tiene que dar larga
lista pero creo que el lado contrario es
un poco más
puede generar más controversia más
escándalo que es cuando le piden que
tiene que utilizar cosas cortas o cosas
pequeñas
por ejemplo es el día de mañana dice el
en el tiro con arco no es que de ahora
en adelante todas las deportistas tienen
que dispararles que baño creo que se
suban quedaría como bueno y entonces
quedaría como muy chocante para mí yo
quería mucho cuando para muchos atletas
pues también haciendo parte de eso
digamos que con la falda pues que no
puede ser tan cortita pues de quien de
parte del reglamento normal entonces si
es la dieta que haber libertad
obviamente algunos puedan con los
reglamentos porque pues si yo a
uniformes que no van a permitir y que el
deportista puede simular correctamente o
cosas por el estilo pues obviamente no
se vería pero la solución no van a hacer
que atletas descubran la solución es
educar en respeto
y la solución es dar la opción de que la
persona se sienta cómoda
bueno valentina y ya para el cierre que
pasa con los deportistas trans que
hicieron su deuda en estos juegos
todavía hay quienes alegan ventaja
física como deportista cuál es su
opinión
bueno te cuento la verdad me apoyo ante
los movimientos y pues sobre todo de las
personas trans para mí es cien por
ciento siento que una persona que se
identifica como mujer y que para nada
tener las condiciones y un hombre a
estar con las condiciones de una mujer
porque siento que yo no va a aumentar su
capacidad física
a comprar gente como nosotros creeríamos
de las personas comúnmente que le harían
es como que a no previó que si antes era
una hombre va a tener más fuerza la
verdad no sería y no sé muy bien cómo
sería la situación en la parte médica
pero pues siento que no hemos visto
ahorita las competencias no logramos
notar como una ventaja una ventaja
pues
una ventaja en mérida en las personas
trans simplemente eran un competidor
competidora más un competidor más y
siento que es muy bueno que lo acepten
de esa manera estamos como como decía
cambiando y que la organización tan
grande como puede ser comité olímpico
internacional permita la participación
de personas trans y den su
reconocimiento es un avance es algo que
es bastante importante ciento tiene
atletas también deberían tener su
espacio y su oportunidad de llegar pues
a competir en donde se sienten pues que
pertenecen los juegos olímpicos yo creo
que son el sueño de
todos los deportistas
pues yo creo que si todos los que
tenemos como participar en juegos
olímpicos nuestra meta es llegar a
nuevos olímpicos
y pues realmente imagínate una persona
trans aparte de que ha tenido que lidiar
con muchas cosas de la sociedad saber
que arrebatarían un sueño que podría ser
uno de los olímpicos que no serían pues
terrible entonces como que darle a abrir
las puertas blanco que parece
maravilloso del algo que nos ayuda a
más conciencia como como pues como
sociedad
pues no siento que haya como una ventaja
así realmente sobre los otros
competidores es una competidora más es
un competidor más gracias valentín a
ustedes por estar con nosotros y a
nuestra audiencia habitual de ellas hoy
sigan en france 24
[Música]